the Joe Rogan experience well it's like
the Pink Floyd line you know living life
of quiet desperation I mean that just
terrifies that's the Rose quote that
most men live lives of quiet desperation
it's one of my favorite quotes ever
because it's true now Jim that guy you
just you're just in this world where you
just can't wait to just run away and how
do people get stuck there how do you
think they get stuck there bills bills
like financial thing hmm yeah
bills and commitment you have an
apartment you have to pay for you have a
car you least you have a wife that you
have to feed you have a child do you
have to raise you have to you have your
mortgage you have your this you have
your that and that's where it all comes
from where do you think opportunity
plays into that well the opportunity
takes place usually when you're young
and you don't have any responsibilities
though that's when you have your options
well your options are severely limited
the more you gather responsibilities
like if I had as a 51 year old father of
three married man pays taxes has a house
and a mortgage and a business and all
that jazz if I had to quit everything
now and struggle the way I struggled as
a stand-up comedian it would never work
but the only way I could be this person
now is if I took that chance when I was
21 when I was dead broke and had my cars
repossessed and all that stuff that's
the only way you you ever get where you
want to go you have to you have to take
a path it's dangerous and most people
want to take the safe path and the safe
path leaves you stuck in quiet
desperation almost every time it's hell
it's hell you're selling insurance or
some other [ __ ] they care zero about but
can people just make that change I mean
you can't believe you have to plan it
out the way you can change is you have
to put aside enough money to give
yourself a window and then you have to
have a plan and you have to spend all
your waking hours outside of whatever
[ __ ] job you do planning your escape and
you have to come to the realization very
clearly that you [ __ ] up and you got
yourself stuck so whatever you're doing
you have
to do it like your life depends on it
and whether it is you're trying to be an
author and you're gonna you're gonna if
you're gonna try to be an author and
you're working eight hours a day plus
commuting plus family responsibilities
or whatever else you have whatever time
that you have you have to attack like
you're trying to save the world you're
trying to save your life you don't want
to drown that one-and-a-half hours a day
that you have to write goddamn you
better be caffeinated and motivated you
got to go you got to get after it and
you got to have discipline that's most
people don't have those things most
people don't understand what it's like
to really go for something and to know
that the consequences of not doing that
are horrific
then you're desperate and yeah but I do
think there is something to be said for
fate and circumstance sure and I always
write I mean people in these military
and environments that I write about and
in these intelligence world environments
fate and circumstance plays a big part
because they too can even get complacent
you know but when your life is on the
line
right a lot of times they have these
experiences where they're like I must
change and that's what I find really
interesting yeah in people sure
desperation
[Applause]